hey guys happy Veda is it a happy vana
I'm not sure I've been having a great
time vlogging every day except I believe
I might have skipped two days I think
sit good boy oh you did a quick one it
was like a quick like look I'm sitting
all my videos have been about him
because basically that's all it's been
we've been just kind of hanging out
we've been doing our little trainings
and I'm about to put another harness on
him he's so little I think he's getting
a little bit bigger now so he's got a
little bit of a little bit of subsidence
no no we got it we gotta work on this
little nibbling thing we got going on
here mmm
this is not working woody oh my okay
why are we why is this happening
everyone that we get is just not good
for you
we gotta go for walks if you weren't so
cute
I'd get so mad if you weren't so cute
I'd get so mad look at you you look so
good
look tell all of your friends how good
you look nice
those little buckles are so heavy on you
you can walk with it on yeah so cute do
you like your harness
[Music]
we don't want to walk you're gonna have
some troubles come on right here I know
we gotta be a good boy come here
now you come here there's no one of the
most important things that I am needing
to work on with Maddie is being able to
travel so I've been trying to find the
perfect sort of travel bag and you know
I don't have all those who like it's the
rank I'm in my purse but honestly I'm
gonna have to be that person because
he's gotta come with you know so I'm
hoping this will work out a little bit
better than the other bag that I got him
it's perfect for like you know in the
car and taking in places but I needed
something a little bit smaller then I
could use because that one's a little
too big for him what's really important
is a lot of people don't think that you
need to put a seat belt on your dog's
carrier in a car but it actually is
extremely important and my mom was
looking into getting things for our
sister's dog like belt things and then I
started doing some searches and looking
at how you're helping me open aren't you
and I was watching videos of dogs and
car crash text and it is traumatizing so
you should always wear a seatbelt so
should your puppies what is it what is
it is it something for you is it
something for you look there's a kitty
in there
like a little sleepy bed so see it has
like a little seatbelt lock he's like
will says not chew it on everything
chill don't have everything oh my gosh
everything everything you nibble nibble
nibble on what you think of inside huh
do you want out come on let's go
[Music]
midnight he wants a play good morning
so are you guys gonna be sad when Vedas
over maybe cuz I've been hosting a lot
of videos way more than I typically post
but it's also been really fun because
I've had my little man and today is
national dog day which is quite
fantastic because really do I need
another excuse to post picture or a
video of my dog do I know I'm drilling
this is gonna be another little
compilation video just some videos that
I had on my iPhone that I've taken on my
camera and they just sort of really
don't make sense cuz I'll just randomly
film him throughout the day of him doing
his little puppy things he's pretty much
taken over all your stuff yep
talking about you the black ops 3 beta
just came out for Xbox I'll probably be
playing that today I've got about 10
videos to edit I haven't done anything
in the past week since I got him and
it's quite unfortunate good afternoon
so today I am going to be shooting some
videos and little Maddy I cannot get
this stuff off of his little eyes I keep
like scrubbing and he just he looks like
a little pig I can't I can't get the
crusts off so fussy but boy are you cute
you just ate so you're I know you're not
hungry
we spend our days looking at each other
I look at him he looks at me he follows
my tootsies Maddy oh good boy
do you know your name do you know how to
sit sit
oh good boy this weekend we're gonna
take our first little puppy kindergarten
class I'm excited and I'm a little
nervous because usually they you know
they tell you not to take your puppies
out with other puppies but this is a
veterinarian approved a little puppy
kindergarten where everything is
sanitized and cleanliness to their
course or not I I think I think he'll do
okay we'll see me when I got it he was
with so many other little puppies but
well I also have to take him to get his
second round of shots tomorrow and I'm
not looking forward to it he's got him
he's gotta get ready to travel because
he's gonna be travelling the end of
September okay so I settled a bunch of
videos today and I got like this weird
like I'm not sure if it was a migraine
but I didn't have a headache but like I
couldn't see for a while like it was the
strangest thing ever so kind of just
took it easy today but now I just took
Maddie for a walk and he did a very good
job the only way that I can trick him
into going for a walk is to make sure
he's hungry because then I bribe him by
saying okay after the walk is over I say
are you hungry he is hungry in fact
these are these little frozen like
nugget things that you honey we're
working on it that you thought out the
night before and I forgot to thaw them
out today so this is his first woman
he's getting of the day he makes I'm
talking to him
and he already had a little solid food
earlier today my hungry little baby well
she runs a fast you hungry
I gotta go they take a nap or something
I'm not sure what happened earlier but
it was a little it was a little strange
I'm not sure if it's like a lack of
sleep
used to get migraines but not very bad
and then I told my sister like what was
happening and she's like well maybe had
a migraine but it's like it have a
headache that's very weird apparently
you can get a migraine without having a
headache
it's okay we're gonna go for a little
ride right honey kind of go for a little
ride it breaks my little heart to see
him in there but he's been so good he
just knows I got him some new treats
shaken I got him a black leash yes you
guys were making fun of him because he
had a pink leash I think the pink was
fashionable I love you little man
internet loves you too Oh baby I know
we're gonna go home soon okay so vada is
almost over
are you gonna be sad or you to miss Shh
I was doing some internet research
because I was still so freaked out about
what happened earlier and it looks like
I had an ocular migraine I was telling
my sister Bree the pharmacist I've never
heard of migraines without actually
having a headache like this is exactly
what I was seeing it was so freaking
weird it just it tripped me out and for
some reason my first thought was wow I
can't see I'm gonna go eat some peanut
chips I'm like okay if I'm gonna go out
like this I'm gonna go out guys what I
laughed too hard I cry okay
thinking back of this situation and my
choices of medicating myself was great
hey you potentially might be dying some
peanuts so dumb all right I'm gonna go
to bed because I'm really tired
Oh another thing I was reading here - it
says about 60% of migraine sufferers it
occurs days or weeks before the migraine
attack symptoms of a migraine can be
subtle may include changes in mood
cravings for certain food or her general
feeling of being tired there's actually
really funny because I was so extremely
tired these past two days and I just
thought that it was because of the dog
but no I don't think it was because I
also had a weird cravings I'm like what
is wrong with me
you made sure I was okay today here's
flip ton all right I'm gonna go
definitely not feeling tip-top shape
I'll see you guys later
we are off to get our we're off to get
our shots he's been such a good little
car traveler I'm super impressed
I'm so proud problem AMA except when he
hears me talking he gets real excited
and he knows I have a spinach feta rap
from Starbucks and you probably want
some of that doesn't even care about
people food just once his food because
his food is probably healthier than most
of the human food that I feed myself I
know you're gonna hate me but
[Music]
good boy that's okay honey yeah just a
little teeny bit for a little bit I play
Maddie's first play time he's gonna
doctor you know we don't like cords look
at him the friends gizmo can you see his
mom and Maddie let's go yep Maddie's
like I am sitting that is better behaved
than you and your old man he goes
through extensive training every day hey
guys how's it going what's today don't
know I mean I know what day it is but
you guys don't know what day it is
because I have completely lost track of
vlogging I got a package here from
Amazon mr. man guess what we have here
guess what we bought in the Amazon
package his favorite toy are these
little lamb chop toys but he's destroyed
them and so I got three of them so he's
gonna be real excited because if he
destroys them then where'd you go good
boy good boy drinking parenting struggle
I should never say that because honestly
the parents more it's just it's so many
props to you I'm struggling with the dog
I don't know how you have raised humans
thanks for watching this really long
vlog it's basically a compilation of the
past couple of days
nothing really made sense at separate
videos so I just put them all together
hope you guys enjoyed it it's kind of
funny just watching a little man grow up
but he's already he's already getting a
little hefty sleepy little pig
he loves his new rug I love his new rug
too because I can sit on the ground and
the Hoth hardwood floor is not comfy Oh
Oh somebody woke up alright guys I'll
see you later don't forget to like this
video and subscribe and all that fun
stuff
I always forget to tell you guys that
but like if you're watching this video
you've already probably subscribed to my
channel so yeah anyway I'll see you guys
later peace out okay keep in my chair
are you trying to distract me
no Activ yeah this is a tactic